parce que nos villes se transforme
perpétuellement nous avons le devoir de
recycler tous ces matériaux yprema votre
partenaire pour un développement durable
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans l'
équilibre votre magazine sur
l'environnement ce mois ci nous abordons
le thème des sols yvelinois à travers un
entretien tout à l'heure nous ferons un
état des lieux sur nos terrains et les
menaces qu'ils rencontrent aujourd'hui
au soler également nous irons à la
rencontre de benoît verbeek navigateur
des essarts le roi qui prépare ses
régates dans un bateau 100% autonome en
énergie
direction ensuite saint-cyr-l'ecole
poursuivre la construction de nouveaux
logements hlm en bois équipée de
panneaux solaires mais tout de suite
nous partons à paris où le célèbre
skipper michel desjoyeaux a été nommé
parrain du solar decathlon de versailles
jonathan willeman pour les images michel
desjoyeaux parrain du solar decathlon
europe de versailles
c'est lors d'un point presse le 17 mars
au ministère de l'égalité des
territoires et du logement que l'annoncé
a été officialisée compétition
internationale d'architecturé
environnementale
le solar élira en juillet prochain le
meilleur projet étudiant de maisons
alimenter en énergie solaire
le navigateur finistériens double
vainqueur du vendée globe a tout de
suite adhéré au projet et apportera
outre sa notoriété une conscience
écologique qui ne date pas d'hier
moi j'ai tout de suite embrayé sur la
proposition
a titre perso tout simplement parce que
je suis passionné de technologies
d'innovation de compétition aussi mais
je suis aussi tout simplement citoyen
mais deux dernières maisons sont
équipées de panneaux solaires thermiques
même en bretagne a su assez de soleil
pour chauffer de l'eau
et sur la prochaine dont j'ai déposé le
permis de construire récemment j'ai bien
l'intention de mettre du solaire
thermique du solaire photovoltaïque de
l'éolien de la récupération d'eau de
pluie pour la première fois organisé en
france la compétition accueillera du 16
juin au 19 juillet les projets de 20
nationalités différentes des projets qui
seront exposées au grand public durant
18 jours près du château de versailles
le solar va ainsi permettre un coup de
projecteur sur la maison écologique du
futur c'est le moyen de montrer qu'on
peut construire différemment qu'on peut
améliorer des bâtiments existants et
qu'on peut faire beaucoup d'économies
d'énergie et utiliser les énergies
renouvelables dans le bâtiment
et puis de montrer aussi toutes les
inventions toutes les innovations qui
sont en cours dans ce secteur lors de ce
solar decathlon europe de projets
français seront présentés en 2012 lors
de la dernière édition c'est un
prototype grenoblois qu'il l'avait
emporté claire chenu et professeur de
science du sol à l'agroparistech de
grignon l'occasion de faire avec elle un
état des lieux de nos sols yvelinois
entretien c'est parti
les retenues bonjour bonjour merci de
nous recevoir ici sur le campus de
grignon le conte le campus agroparistech
écoutez ce un plaisir nous sommes ici
pour parler de l'état de nos sols
on va commencer par une petite
présentation qu'est ce qu'un seul en
bonne santé car je n'ai pas écouté je
vous dirais qu'à un sol en bonne santé
c'est un sol qui est capable durablement
de réaliser les fonctions d'un sol alors
les fonctions d'un sol c'est
principalement d'être support de la
croissance des végétaux qu'il s'agisse
de production agricole qu'il s'agisse
des forêts ou de milieux naturels
c'est insolent les seuls sons reçoivent
soit l'interface entre l'atmosphère les
eaux donc reçoivent des eaux reçoivent
les déchets nos activités c'est un seul
qui est capable de stocker de recycler
et de transformer ce qu'il reçoit en
particulier pour permettre ensuite
alimentation minérale des plantes et
puis des sols ont d'autres fonctions
alors c'est un réservoir de biodiversité
un seul en bonne santé c'est un sol qui
héberge une diversité importante et les
sols les berges diversité action
fantastique c'est assez extraordinaire
et on attend des sols donc voilà un seul
site en bonne santé 500 qui est capable
durablement de réaliser ses fonctions
clés retenus nos sols yvelinois sont-ils
en bonne santé aujourd'hui écoute n1 ce
liévinois sont menacés ils sont menacés
directement la première menace et
l'artificialisation donc là vous nous
sommes dans une zone péri urbaine dont
il ya beaucoup de constructions et
d'ailleurs le sol sert à ce moment-là
renseigne salon kit support à ces
constructions
mais ces constructions les routes les
voies d'accès les parkings
imperméabilise le sol et font par
exemple que l'on ne peut plus sans
filtre et dans les sols une fois qu'un
sol est recouvert par du béton et ben il
n'est plus non plus un réservoir de
biodiversité la lpo puis remplir ses
fonctions
donc ça c'est une très très forte menace
sur les sols et l'artificialisation
progresse rapidement par rapport à elle
progresse rapidement en france de
manière générale et particulièrement en
ile-de-france s'agirait c'est la
première menace la deuxième c'est que
les sols heures plus tôt pour les sols
cultivés les sols s'appauvrissent en
matière organique matières organiques
c'est une composante des sols qui est
très important dans leur fertilité et
des décennies même des plus que des
décennies d'agriculture intensive faut
qu'on a eu tendance à exporter plus
qu'on apportait matières organiques et
un seul don qu'ils s'appauvrissent les
conséquences et que seuls sont plus
sensibles à l'érosion même si a pas
beaucoup d'érosion dans dans les
yvelines sont plus sensibles à l'érosion
qui sont plus sensibles au tassement
qu'ils hébergent moins de biodiversité -
d'organismes vivants et puis sinon il y
à une contamination diffuse alors qui
est pas très importante qui est bien
moindre que dans d'autres pays dans des
contextes similaires
alors qui est en particulier lens il y
ait ou à la proximité des villes des
activités industrielles plomb cadmium
hydrocarbures poyart o matic et puis un
peu pesticides liés aux activités
agricoles ça sont des toutes petites
toner sur des grands territoires
ça ne met pas en jeu pour le moment de
manière critique introduire la qualité
des produits alimentaires même s'il faut
qu'on fasse il faut vraiment qu'on fasse
mieux malgré cela la retenue est ce que
ces seuls restent fertile alors je
dirais dedans en ile-de-france et dans
les yvelines une grande partie des sols
sont des sortes d'une fertilité
remarquable on a des sols qui sont
profonds qui retiennent bien l'eau qui
retiennent bel bien les éléments
nutritifs qui a fait un si petit lu de
france et autant développer cette
historiquement les gens sont implantés
là où sept et riches là où il était
facile de cultiver la vous pouvez tirer
la richesse
et donc voilà nous sommes environnés de
soldes une très très grande qualité
donc tous les sols n'ont pas les mêmes
qualités dans les yvelines et donc on
part pour beaucoup de ceux face à tout
ce qui est sur les plateaux
d'ile-de-france va être bientôt de
plaisir par exemple on a des sols
absolument remarquable même pour une
agriculture qu'on peut considérer comme
bio alors c'est qu'elle sait que cette
capacité c'est d'être profond pour que
ce à dire que les racines pas bien
explorer milieu le fait de bien retenir
l'eau de bien retenir les éléments du
tri ça c'est important qu'elles que
soient l'agriculture que l'on que l'on
fait processus biologiques il faut que
les organismes vivants organismes
vivants faut effectivement qui est petit
ami n'en et surtout c'est peut-être ça
qui est plus de huit ans dans les sols
agricoles aujourd'hui en france qu'il y
ait beaucoup de matière organique et
beaucoup à manger
voilà donc ça passe par un ré
enrichissement des sols en matière
organique
l'avenir commence annonce-t-il alors
commence alors sa vie avait dit pour moi
il est très important qu'on se dote de
règles pour gérer à l'échelle d'un
territoire les services on pourrait dire
qu'on attend des sols sains ou implantés
de manière préférentielle les
infrastructures les logements
l'agriculture donc ça c'est un point il
en a besoin de mieux quantifier ces
services que rend des sols aux sociétés
eu à notre société à nos sociétés et
puis sinon pour améliorer les sols dans
un contexte agricole basque important
par une des choses très importantes
c'est les enrichir matières organiques
alors là il ya plusieurs manières de
faire on a parlé d' effectivement des
apports d'effluents de l'élevage d
apport de compost
ça peut être aussi en couvrant les sens
il faut éviter en fait de laisser les
sols nus exposé à la pluie comme vous
pouvez
ici et ceci en utilisant des plantes de
couverture des planteurs dans des
intercultures donc ça ce sont des
pratiques qui permettent d'enrichir les
sols en matière organique de stimuler
l'activité des organismes vivants
l'agroforesterie aussi est un type
d'agriculture très intéressant ce qu'il
ya beaucoup de travaux en ce moment qui
apparemment stimule la biodiversité et
enrichit les sols en matière organique
donc oui il ya un certain nombre de
voies de recherche de voix d'application
de voie de développement mise au point
par des agriculteurs sur les canaux qui
cherchent les chercheurs voilà y'a ya de
quoi faire merci beaucoup pour votre vos
explications car show no mercy son
bateau il la pensée 100% autonome en
énergie benoît verbeek nous raconte son
parcours de navigateurs respectueux de
l'environnement et le diwan pour les
images
benoît verbeek 39 ans n'est pas un
navigateur comme les autres depuis l'âge
de 14 ans passionné de voile cet
ingénieur automobile dans la vie
développe depuis 2007 un bateau 100%
autonome en énergie
et c'est en observant les plus grands
que son projet nommé gulliver a germé
dans son esprit le premier vendée globe
qui avait fait jean-pierre dick où il
avait dû faire face à une panne de
générateur dès l'entrée du grand sud et
donc finir son sa course uniquement avec
ses panneaux solaires et a fini 5e ce
qui est dans l'absolu une trop bonne
place et encore plus quand c'est un
premier vendée globe est deux fois plus
encore quand on a que cette source
d'énergie
benoît verbeek tombe peu après sur un
article dans un magazine spécialisé où
il découvre comment fabriquer un bateau
écolo pour lui plus besoin de carburant
ou de moteurs thermiques
désormais c'est uniquement grâce aux
vents et aux panneaux solaires que son
voilier fonctionnera bouilloire pilote
automatique ou feux de signalement
tous marchent désormais à l'électrique
un choix logique pour ce skipper
sensible à l'écologie
chez moi je me chauffe au bois
j'utilise trois stères de bois par an ce
qui très peu simplement parce qu'on a
isolé la maison le chauffe eau solaire
et fournit quasiment toute l'eau chaude
même enfant enfin chez moi on se
souciait mais mes parents récupérer
l'eau de pluie
dix ans avant qu'on en parle niveau
budget ses panneaux solaires et son
moteur électrique ne coûte pas plus cher
qu'une installation thermique classique
voire même un peu moins selon lui pour
financer son projet benoît verbeek fait
taper le financement participatif sur
internet jusqu'au lui mais il prendra
ensuite le départ de deux régates en
solitaire sur son six mètres 50 dont les
sables d'olonne en juillet prochain
exporter de scandinavie par un
architecte l'idée de logements sociaux
en bois arrive à saint cyr l'école
un concept qui devrait faire des petits
et dont nous parle sabrina c'est fini un
chantier en apparence comme les autres
ou presque car dans ces constructions
dash est même en cours à saint cyr
l'école on pense avant tout
développement durable ici la structure
des immeubles est réalisée en bois le
bois déjà un coffee shop génération qui
est plus important que le béton
dès qu'on vous toucher du bois et c'est
bon il fait pas froid vous touchez du
béton c'est froid ce sont des bâtiments
qui sont très très bien désolé pour
travailler dans le sens d'une économie d
énergie est aussi utiliser une énergie
qui est renouvelable le bois ont fait
pousser des arbres on découpe on
construit avec un peu poussé un autre
arbre le béton au folie's on tire
toujours dans les énergies fossiles
il ya une brune elle tient sa
connaissance du bois d'un long séjour en
scandinavie pour lui la construction de
ce type d'habitation collective et
appelé à se développer dans l'hexagone
selon lui le bois permet une économie
d'énergie d'environ 20% par rapport au
béton le bailleur lui a en tout cas été
sensible à ce procédé on cherche avant
tout à faire des économies d'énergie des
économies de ressources et limiter les
consommations les les productions de gaz
à effet de serre donc le bois est un
matériau qui n'y répond à toutes ces
problématiques
c'est le seul matériau de construction
qui est durable et qui naturel autre
démarche en faveur de l'écologie
l'installation de panneaux solaires qui
permettra aux familles de réaliser des
économies
60 % de l'eau chaude sera autofinancé
grâce au solaire thermique
les occupants ne devront financer que
les 40% restant un gain non négligeable
pour les futurs locataires qui devraient
emménager d'ici trois mois
c'est la fin de votre numéro d'
équilibre mais avant de se quitter on
passe à l'agenda environnementale du 1er
avril au 21 mai venez découvrir une
exposition sur la transition écologique
à l'aide de modules interactifs et de
tablettes numériques et devenez
imparfaite éco citoyens tout en vous
amusant
mercredi 2 avril découvrez les coulisses
du recyclage sous forme de petits jeux
apprenez à mieux comprendre le tri
sélectif et les bons gestes à adopter au
quotidien
enfin le samedi 5 avril accompagné par
deux éducatrices écologistes profiter
d'un parcours pédestre à magny les
hameaux pour découvrir la biodiversité
en ville et le tri des déchets voilà
c'est tout pour cette émission on se
retrouve le 18 avril prochain et d'ici
là n'oubliez pas la terre est notre mère
respectons la salut
[Musique]